i'm just attacking
what's the worst that can happen you
just wanted to [ __ ] with me because i
want to move fast oh okay i want to [ __ ]
with you for sure
let me try this one dude
bringing the queen out oh that's my girl
oh
this girl is crazy
since timing is everything
let me kind of get some time away from
this [ __ ]
what do you think about pawns you like
oh no don't do that don't bring stuff
out yeah let me get some other people in
the party i'm gonna like sacrifice
pieces to make you
make you thank you you're doing good
ponder me right but since you're gonna
do that and i figured you was gonna do
that i'm gonna i'm gonna let you i'm
gonna let you do what you want to do so
i could do what i wanted thank you this
is good
he's not taking the quote bait that's
not an actual bait
i gotta threaten you somehow i'm gonna
make you nervous
here we go
oh
that's your kung fu technique
to make me nervous
i don't know if i'm getting nervous from
that one watch your king that's all i
gotta say i know i see you as you trying
to punch me in my face and [ __ ] yeah
we don't play around yeah he can have
the pawns i can have the pawn no you can
have the pawns i'm just gonna knock you
out
oh it's going to knock me out
you guys hear this guy
[Laughter]
while we're still even
you have like so many options it's
overwhelming actually i'm glad you see
it that way because i'm feeling the same
a grand master would just uh
forfeit here
but i'm not i'm not that i'm not that i
like that because i'm a higher level i
like well i like to i like the pitch of
that yeah he's like a grand master was
just forfeit here so i'm trying to
paralyze you with too many good choices
until you make a mistake
which is good i mean that's the meaning
you should be scared because you don't
want to make a mistake on camera that'll
be embarrassing
because you're because you're winning
you're dominating yeah and then you can
but he makes a mistake on camera
what would the world think of that
what would they tell him back home i'd
be nervous for you that's all i'm saying
yeah i'm getting a little bit nervous
but not totally
you know why i'm not totally nervous oh
oh why is that
oh you want to know
i i guess i'm just gonna have to wait
and find out
okay so in that case
since this is one of those matches
a friendly match yeah a funny match
i was gonna go for either that or war i
think i i think i'm gonna let that be
the way we eat
you are you cool with that yeah you give
me a rook or what yeah why not okay okay
you're gonna give me
this
this this is great
because a generous man does okay you
something to eat you gave me something
to eat
i'm gonna give you
something to eat
all right
okay that was good i hope it tastes good
yeah i did i feel good i'm winning
i'm winning i hope everybody liked it on
the official chess point system i'm up
by
pawn if i were to gable two rooks that's
probably generally not that generous i
appreciate that yeah the people would
have been talking about me
for years to come
yeah man
hello look at this this guy is getting
nervous he's like what you doing you got
it
yeah you know 100
so let me count my money you count your
money yeah my money oh you got more
money than me
whoa that was a bad move right there
brother
the
that one did
hmm
what do you want to do with that you
want to zoom in on that
[Laughter]
you know they say white guys love black
women yeah
now i know now i know what that means
thank you
that's a tough looking check yeah i can
trick you into a draw somehow all right
i think that way
you could take this as far as you want
to take it but i i think uh in the
interest of time we're running out of
time you have to go man
thank you man
that was beautiful
you